hello and welcome to this video I am
taxius my opponent you get the friggin
Italian like every other game okay yeah
I always get problems them from these
positions it looks like not much is
going on but still still I tend to get
into trouble really wonder me and have
to switch to something else entirely
like not a six but he fired on something
something else is it okay so let's see
what happens here bit of a prick Lou 55
but ahead of the Inns of these a feeling
that this should be right given the fact
that he has decentralized his pieces
however now looking at it I'm not sure
that this helps all that much Queenie a
three could be a move that makes sense
yeah or something like that I have night
f4 but doesn't help
okay and no it takes d5 with the bishop
place 94 wins upon huh a position is
actually not very comfortable Wow
ha I don't see Abel move absolutely not
taking only three is rubbish if I was
hanging just just like that Queen d6
doesn't work f6 looks bad on account of
default oh yuck so d5 was bad i opened
the position in an untimely way I'm
running is there some way that I can
work with the night discovery here
doesn't look like i can just rubbish
position what can you do i'm just a pawn
down and have a bad position amazing so
we defy this is just bad i just have a
bad fielding positions i don't know
is there any other movement range is
real Quincy five min young Queen g3
death knight h5 though this is probably
by its hesitating sorry and Quincy 5s 97
then you can go back to h5 huh so what
does that mean this is actually still
somewhat playable but here i don't see a
move here 9725 is of course fine the
Queen doesn't have many squares be six
foot push it back but and will this 45
not sure my design clean edge five
didn't lead to anything no yep just a
poor down and more than one minute down
on the clock that's probably not helping
all that much but we'll see we need five
group g6 hope for the best
like almost primo 56-bit and night well
now Queen at five no maybe 25 I actually
place that that somewhat strange move
I'm not sure of strange the right word
but anyway so 90 f 4p still have a
couple of Queen moves
I don't know do have some compensation
as a queen of a little bit off and go
[Music]
tonight f5 stuff mating time learning I
can take on f6 which you didn't do maybe
Queenie for like covering looks passes
before might be a move just play play
the pond wealthy area does that I can
try put this on d5
well it looks very it looks like an
extremely loose move Queen f3 or
something no I will probably doesn't
work for some reason or another and
we'll see
by 27 those are the Mossad get get me
really into trouble him now that Lucas
all trying so damn black and one now I
was bad but that old stuff was bad maybe
I had some chances later even but I
totally hated this position here Wow
probably d5 is just rubbish I should go
see six something that the engine also
suggests some things I know you're
sitting there in this nonsense position
just a pawn down absolutely absolutely
nothing yeah mayor to go to see five but
I don't have anything special I just 14
more or less nothing I didn't have any
particularly good idea here yeah so
cannot coordinate all that valve k
look-see to oops sorry look see too
we're still putting up some resistance
him 195 ever what we're we're here look
c2 yeah maybe after keep this covered
all the time I was thinking to go to d5
you can probably just do that well now
you can fight it it's not funny this
okay Queenie 6 actually continued but i
only have 17 seconds anyway now I was a
bad position again the out of the out of
the Italian game I really suck in this
opening well thanks for watching